معنا من حيفا ايهاب جبارين الكاتب المختص
في الشان الاسرائيلي اهلا بك سيد ايهاب
جبارين اذا هذه التصريحات لنتنياهو على
خلفيه الدعم الذي جلبه وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لويد اوستن الى
اسرائيل كيف يمكن ان يترجم على الارض في
الوقت الذي تتسع فيه رقعه الاحتجاجات من
عائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين المطالبه
بابرام صفقه تبادل
جديده نعم تحياتي استاذه مريم صباح الخير
يعني بطبيعه الحال ربما حتى هنالك ملحوضه
على الهامش يجب الوقوف عندها نتنياهو منذ
اليوم الاول لهذه الحرب ولهذه العدوان كان
قد صرح واصر انه يتوجب علينا البدء
بالتحدث
بالعربيه ولكن يعني باعتقادي نتنياهو فقد
قدرته ليس فقط بالتحدث بالعربيه بل كذلك
بالعبريه مع جمهوره في الداخل وبالمقابل
نحن نرى ان حماس ليست فقط تجيد التحدث
بالعبريه بل كذلك بالاسرائيلي يعني عندما
تفتتح هذه الافتتاحيه في التش لخير لد ز
كنا هي لا تتركون ل نعجز هنا هي يعني هذا
الاقتباس من التوراه وما الى ذلك لديه ذلك
الزخم في داخل الشارع الاسرائيلي لديه
الكثير من الضغوطات في داخل الشارع
الاسرائيلي وباعتقادي ان النقطه المحوريه
هنا ربما يعني اذا كان هنالك تسلسل لذات
الاستراتيجيات السابقه النقطه المحوريه
هنا هي الحصانه الاسرائيليه الحصانه
الاسرائيليه لم تعد كما كانت في المرحله
الاولى من الحرب ما قبل الهدنه الاى
ولماذا هذا لان بات واضحا ان التحركات
السياسيه بدات تطفو الى السطح اكثر فاكثر
والاعلام بطبيعه الحال لديه الكثير من
المواقف السياسيه في داخل اسرائيل اي نعم
هنالك بعض القنوات التي لم تع على سبيل
المثال هذا الشريط كما كانت تعمل في
السابق ولكن قنوات اخرى على سبيل المثال
عرضت هذا هذا الشريط و تم التداول به بل
يمكن القول ان حتى هنالك قنوات بكل معنى
الكلمه شغلها الشاغل مثل الثانيه عش
والثالث عش شغلها الشاغل هي قضايا
المختطفين وفي هذا هنالك موقف سياسي منحنى
سياسي مؤثر على الشارع الاسرائيلي لديه
الكثير من الضغوطات في الشارع الاسرائيلي
وهنا النقطه المهمه جدا اذا اذا اردنا ان
نعود الى نتنياهو في طبيعه الحال نتنياهو
عمل او يعمل في الاسابيع الاخيره على
تصعيد الانشقاق في داخل الشعر الاسرائيلي
بين قسمين في المره الاولى حاول ان يعني
يبلور هذا الانشقاق في داخل منتدى ذوي
الاسرى بمفهوم كذا او كاخر بان يكون هناك
لك القسم المناهض له او الذي يساير
سياساته وراينا ذلك كيف ترجم في داخل
اللقاءات مع الكابينت وما الى ذلك الى حد
الاشتباك مفهوم كذا او كاخر ولكن التصعيد
الاخير وربما يجب الوقوف عنده كثيرا هو
منتدى
امهات الجنود القتلى كذلك المناهض
لبنيامين نتنياهو والذي ينادي بسياسات
بنيامين نتنياهو واستمرار الحرب وما الى
ذلك طبعا بطبيعه الحال هنا نتحدث عن جمهور
من اليمين المتطرف هذا الاحت دام باعتقاده
كذلك هو مشهد فريد من نوعه لم يكن في
السابق في حروبات اسرائيل ابدا نتنياهو
يستخدم ذات الاستراتيجيات التي تغذى منها
في السابق ما قبل السابع من اكتوبر على
مدى 10 اشهر انشقاق في داخل الشارع
الاسرائيلي يستمد هذه الاستراتيجيات اللي
يترجمها الان في محاوله اضعاف الضغط في
داخل الشارع ولكن نقطه مهمه جدا
433 عدد القتلى في صفوف الجيش حتى هذه
اللحظه الرقم الذهبي هو 500 الشرع
اسرائيلي بطبيعه الحال لن يستطيع فقط
الوقوف عند عدد الاسر بل كذلك عند عدد
القتلى هذين الرقمين هم رقمين ذهب ذهبيين
بكل معنى الكلمه طيب وعلى الرغم من تصاعد
ربما هذه الارقام وارتفاع عدد الجنود
الاسرائيليين القتل والجرحى في هذه
المعارك البريه وهذه الضغوط التي تزداد
والاحترام مع الشارع والانشقاقات في صفوف
السياسيه هل يلمس تاثير كل ذلك على القرار
الاسرائيلي الذي يصر على استمرار العمليه
البريه ولا حديث عن صفقه
جديده جميل جدا يعني ربما نقتبس بذلك ما
قاله اليوم ابن يورا متسر وهو احد احد
الاسرى الذين كانوا في
داخل الذين بينوا في داخل الشريط الاخير
قالها بكلمات جدا بسيطه يعني الانطباع
العام انه لا يوجد هنالك افق لا يوجد
هنالك ديد لاين لاتمام هذه الصفقه بطبيعه
الحال هذه الجمله يجب الوقوف عندها لانه
في نهايه المطاف نحن نتحدث انها خرجت من
ابن احد الاسرى عندما لا يكون هنالك افق
بطبيعه الحال هنالك تصعيد في داخل
الضغوطات في داخل الشارع الاسرائيلي انا
باعتقاد ان الشارع السيلي سوف يشهد موجه
ضغوطات اكثر فاكثر في الايام المقبله على
غرام ما رايناه بالمناسبه ما قبل الهدنه
الاولى لكن هذه المره بشكل محتدم اكبر
واكثر هذه النقطه الاولى والجزئيه الاولى
التي يجب ان نقف عندها في نهايه المطاف
النقطه الاولى وكذلك جزئيه مهمه جدا
اسرائيل يعني او او او ما اثبت حتى هذه
اللحظه في في نهايه المطاف في كل على غرار
الاكثر من 70 يوم الذين مضوا العمليات
العسكريه وهي ربما يعني الذريعه الاولى
لبنيامين نتنياهو في التورل البري
العمليات العسكريه اثبتت انها ليس فق تقتل
المدنيين في داخل القطاع بل كذلك تقتل
الاسرى وتقتل الجنود الذين يحاولون تحرير
الاسرى في في في هذه المعادله والمره
الوحيده التي استطاع فيها اسرائيل تحرير
الاسرى هي كانت عن طريق الهدنه اشكرك
ايهاب جبارين الكاتبه مختص في الشان
الاسرائيلي من حيفا